one of my favorite things about the long
now is the interval bar you know go to
get a breve cappuccino a whiskey maybe
even a bug burger our next speaker is
the architect who built and designed it
please welcome out Jeffrey McGrew so
automation is fundamentally changing the
construction industry this force that's
disrupting lots of other industries as
well presents a lot of opportunities and
challenges for construction but a lot of
downsides to as an architect who's been
personally empowered by automation I'd
like to share some my thinking about it
today so my name is Jeffrey and I help
run a design-build architecture studio
name because we can we're not only
architects we also help build our
projects using digital fabrication
through automation and as we said we're
very proud to been part of the team that
helped build the interval so already my
drafting is largely automated I don't
really draw anything anymore I create
intelligent parametric 3d models virtual
buildings and the computer in turn
produces all my drawings and plans and
details for me these Building
Information models as they're called are
then used to build the actual project
too so a great example of this is that
the long now at the interval we wanted
to build this display cabinet under the
stairs and so we went off a laser scan
of the stairs we 3d bundled all the
parts to fit together just so cut them
all out on a cnc routing table which is
a big robot put them all together and
installed it so no drawings were made of
that cabinet at all by using automated
tools to help design produce and manage
the project we're empowered to be able
to focus on how to make things more
interesting than how to make them all in
the first place but why is this even
important well honestly because
buildings are important buildings
consume almost half our energy and then
waste a third of it they're responsible
for almost a third of our landfill waste
and and the whole industry is wildly
inefficient we desperately need a better
way to be doing this so what are some of
the problems and challenges with
automation well one is that automation
surprisingly is really fragile trading
redundancy for efficiency is an awesome
deal up until everything stops working
because a single thing is wrong and in
construction there's always something
wrong also sometimes we try to automate
the wrong things like 3d printing
buildings which is really just 3d
printing concrete walls which is cool
but walls are easy and cheap and anybody
can make them what we actually really
need is
way to automate the replacement of old
heating systems and existing buildings
that are wildly and efficient also all
this automation produces a lot of data
not all of its useful nest thermostats
wireless sensors in concrete and smart
hard hats that track workers on the job
site are all really cool app enabled
tweeting refrigerators not so much so
you can drown in all this data and
there's also some problems that are
really specific to buildings like
buildings aren't cars cars are mass
produce items that are made from custom
parts buildings are totally custom items
made for mass produce parts so we can't
just go copy what smart people like
Tesla are already doing when it comes to
automation also every building is the
result of four huge opaque and
conflicting forces that are all hyper
local to the exact spot that the
building is sitting in right so there's
all kinds of hidden risks and unforeseen
consequences and it makes it almost
impossible to standardize anything in
the construction industry construction
also works in its own time frame a
really big Hospital project can take 10
or 15 years to complete long enough that
the CAD used to originally design the
project is so outdated that it now has
to be run on virtual machines emulating
old hardware to be run at all and also
buildings have a deep cultural relevance
and when it comes to culture we mostly
care about the things that other people
have done so Mozart helped create a dice
game that will automatically generate
gazillions of waltzes that nobody cares
about because these waltzes are boring
so even if we could fully automate
construction we might not care so what
do we do about some of these problems
well I think if we create semi automated
systems that are focused on empowering
people and building trust in the
construction team we can enjoy some of
the upsides while avoiding some of the
downsides now some people going to get
automated out of a job absolutely
probably I mean you know but I'd argue
that instead when the focus is
empowering people by automating things
to make them be able to do a better job
than try and replace them you get much
better results out of it because people
are awesome they're clever they're
adaptable they're anti fragile it's
really great from the 70s you know a
great example GM went all in on
automation buying tons of robots to
replace Union factory workers Toyota
developed a bunch of semi automated
systems to help empower everybody to
deliver great quality so Te'o too
focused on the people got much better
results out of it so by using automation
to do the eighty percent like easy tasks
so we can focus on the twenty percent
like
you know more higher value tasks we're
empowered like when we were building the
interval for the automation to do the
heavy lifting so we can just focus on
how to make it as interesting as
possible and increasing the amount of
data without increasing the trust just
leads to more noise and confusion so
automated systems that help build the
amount of trust in the team and between
the systems that they're working with is
going to have a much bigger result like
a great example at any given plan set
that I produce only about a third of it
is actually the building of its content
the other two-thirds is us being
redundantly explicit because the city
doesn't trust us and we don't trust the
contractor so we have to be extremely
explicit and clear about what we're
doing even if it's the same stuff
everybody always does over and over the
same code the same drawings so just to
conclude we desperately need better ways
to build semi automated systems that
help empower people and build trust is
one way that we can get there we have a
lot to build an even more to fix and we
desperately need a better way to go
about it thank you very much
you